what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another aong of Ice and Fire
and Game of Thrones update video in this
new video I will be discussing some very
interesting information regarding the
Jon Snow show that is under development
at HBO I have found a source who says
HBO is looking to release the Jon Snow
Series in May of
2025 now I want to be the first one to
say I'm not able to confirm this
information this is not an official
announcement from HBO The only reason
why I'm even making this video is
because there's already other game own
and A Song of Ice and Fire Creator
saying this information might be
accurate the anonymous source who did
release this information said they work
for HBO now that might be a lie however
it certainly would not be the first time
someone at HBO leaked information onto
the internet it does happen every single
year with each new season of their Game
of Thrones or House of the Dragon shows
now before I show you everything they
said I have to let all of you know about
this amazing new game I'd like to thank
the sponsor of today's video Dungeon
Hunter 6 the latest Edition in the
Dungeon Hunter franchise after several
releases starting back in 2009 they now
welcome the highly anticipated addition
to this renowned series and I can assure
you that the weight was incredibly
rewarding now Dungeon Hunter 6 is a
mobile arpg with a unique hero collector
feature in a stunning fantasy style this
gameplay features a fast-paced combat
Style with various builds and skills to
utilize as you fight big bosses and what
I love most is it's absolutely free to
play you can download it now using using
the link in the description or by
scanning my QR code on the screen in
Dungeon under 6 killing a boss is not
the end for every boss you want to
defeat the game has a unique mechanism
by which you can not only loot ride and
fly them but also summon up to three of
them onto the battlefield to become
members of your quid you can make them
follow you anywhere and perform combo
skills you can also shape shift into
them to harness the ultimate power when
you reach the late game this is such a
cool mechanism that I haven't seen done
in the genre before there is over 100
uniquely designed bosses to conquer and
explore new classes and units updated
monthly the fun of utilizing them in
battle is endless now Dungeon Hunter 6
takes its 3D graphics performance to the
next level with stunning skill animation
optimized for multicasting ensuring that
you have the best visual experience and
smooth this Combat on mobile devices you
can download this amazing new game for
free on both Android and iOS by using my
link in the description or by scanning
the QR code on your screen if you're
reviewing it on PC to get a special
starter pack worth $50 including 10
summoning Scrolls one SSR Lieutenant
demonic wolf and one accessory pack once
you've downloaded Dungeon Hunter 6 you
can use your game account to enter the
launch Lucky Spin event for free to win
great prizes like the new iPhone 15 Pro
Max A PS5 an Apple Watch and lots more
starting on October 15th make sure you
check out my description for details you
don't want to miss out on this amazing
new offer once again I have to thank
dungeon hter six for sponsoring today's
video all right now let's have a look at
what this anonymous source had to say
they gave a very interesting update
about HBO's Jon Snow series over on
everyone's favorite website Reddit it
says the target release date for Game of
Thrones snow is May 11th of
2025 as of right now HBO is referring to
this series as ghost the only thing
agreed on is the schedule they have to
work with there is no start date set in
stone although the goal is to start by
cember of
2023 that's obviously only a few months
away Kid Harrington will be an executive
producer but no other names have been
officially revealed It also says they've
been granted four months of script
writing although they have most likely
already started 8 months of filming and
5 to 6 months of post- production an
extra month has also been granted for
re-shoot scheduling conflicts or some
unforeseen sickness we should expect to
see this show in late spring or early
summer in
2025 I have no other information on this
show my line of work was simply
scheduling and finding out the most
lucrative block to release upcoming
shows all right now as I said before I
have no way of confirming any of the
information I'm usually very hesitant to
believe anything on Reddit although this
is where most leaked information is
found like I said what I do find
interesting however is how there are
already some other Game of Thrones in A
Song of Ice and Fire creators who said
they think it sounds accurate now if you
look at everything again you will see
that said HBO's goal was to start
working on the show this December that
does sound like it could be right
considering we know HBO was already
working on this idea many years ago we
found out HBO was working on the Jon
Snow Series last year when House of the
Dragon first season was releasing that
was when the information was revealed to
all of us however George R Martin said
they had already been working on the
idea for much longer he even said he
doesn't know how they kept it a secret
for so long let me show you George R
Martin's not a Blog update about this
Jon Snow show show because he also
revealed a lot of insightful information
he said yes there is a Jon Snow show in
development our working title for the
show is snow there are still four
liveaction successor shows in
development in HBO word got out about
three of them some time ago there's
10,000 ships the show about neria who's
helmed by Amanda seagull there's the sea
snake AKA nine voyages with Bruno heler
and the Duncan egg show the Hedge Knight
or Knight of the Seven Kingdoms that has
Steve Conrad as the writer I think some
of these were officially announced in
other cases the news leaked out these
things always seem to leak there's so
many of us involved writers agents and
everyone has assistance and there's
always the guy who runs the Xerox
machine this information does get out
there somehow snow has been in
development almost as long as the other
three but for whatever reason it was
never announced and it never leaked
until now but yes it is true this was
not an official announcement from HBO so
it seems there was another leak now
there's not much more I can say not
until HBO gives me a green light it
seems as though Amelia has already
mentioned that snow was Kit's idea in a
recent interview so that's already out
there it was kid Harrington who brought
the idea to us I cannot give you the
names of the writers or showrunners
since that has not been cleared for
releas yet but kit brought them too his
own team and they're terrific now
there's various rumors floating around
about my involvement or lack thereof I
am involved just as I am with the Hedge
Knight and the Seas snake and 10,000
ship and all the animated shows not to
mention Kit's team has visited me here
in Santa Fe and worked with me in my own
team of brilliant talented writers and
Consultants to hammer out the show so as
you can see we already know the show is
official it's been under development in
HBO for a number of years the new source
says they want to Begin work in December
which like I said does sound accurate
since they have been already developing
it for so long the only thing that might
hold this show back from actually moving
forward right now is the damn writers
and actors strike as we all know
everything has been shut down due to
those strikes thankfully it seems they
are finally resolving that issue
hopefully that means everyone will be
able to get back to work and all the
Game of Thrones shows at HBO can move
ahead once again I would love for the
Jon Snow series to release in 2025
because that would mean we will get
another Game of Thrones show during the
offseason of House of the dragon that
would be amazing because then there
would be some Game of Thrones and A Song
of Ice and Fire on our televisions every
year not to mention we are still waiting
for the Duncan egg series as well as you
all know that show was already given a
full series order that show will be here
no matter what we just need the strikes
to end so everyone can get Fair wages
and get back to work now before I go I
want to ask all of you if you can show
some love by slapping a like on the
video for those of you who don't know
today actually makees s years since I
created this Channel and started making
videos it is kind of crazy to think 7
years years have gone by already it has
been a wild ride starting back when
season 7 of Game of Thrones leaked
online roughly a whole year before the
show would release I still remember all
the excitement surrounding the fandom
back then when we were all guessing how
the show would end I also remember how
uncertain I was about the future of my
channel After Game of Thrones ended the
fans were so angry and everyone was so
divided I wasn't sure if the Game of
Thrones brand as a whole would recover
thankfully House of the Dragon had a
solid first season and now most of us
are looking forward to the series about
Duncan egg and even the one about Jon
Snow as long as we stay heading in this
direction I might be here for another
seven years making videos about George R
Martin's amazing universe so I just
wanted to take a moment to thank all of
you for showing your love and support
over the years I would not still be here
without it as always I want to thank all
of you for watching another video I hope
everyone has a great day I will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]